all right I think this is yeah it's on
all right so hi everybody
as you see I'm once again in a new place
hopefully this will be the last place
that I'm gonna be for until I move into
our new house the house where we are
here it was also flooded and but just
less so we were able to rent it it's in
our city so it's close by we are working
on the plans for our for the renovations
of our house as some of you who maybe
follow me closely have heard because we
have to go back to our house we don't
really have a choice to leave and
because we don't want to put our kids
back in the basement they don't want to
go back in the basement it was a quite a
traumatic experience for for them to go
through this crazy flood and seeing
their house in the water and everything
so um so yeah so we are going to put a
second floor on our house that is going
to be that's the plan I've already
talked to the bank and luckily I've
always I've always not have a very big
mortgage I'll be able to borrow so so
yeah so that's what's happening and so I
guess the house once which renovated
will be appropriate for our family until
till we die hopefully I'm trying to get
Andrew Gould to do some of the designing
I figured if I'm going to remake my
house I'm going to try to make it at
least as beautiful as I can afford to
make it and so maybe Andrew will do some
of the drawing for either some of the
outside some of the details or some of
the inside I'm hoping to try to actually
include some carving in the in the
either its am architectural carving or
something inside the house until now our
house has always been just kind of uh
has been understood as a way a kind of
halfway house we always felt like it was
not our home that we were just there
it's a very small house and you know
it's it's kind of plastic it's a it's a
kind of plastic suburban house we always
felt like we were there waiting for some
day to have enough money to move but but
yeah but life
you know pushed us in a direction where
now we have to fix it so if we're gonna
fix it we're going to try to make it
beautiful so there that's some news on
that just for other news in terms of the
the Chicago event don't forget I am
going to be in Chicago on Saturday the
26th you can find on my website the hour
think it's at 7:00 something like that
don't trust me here it's at Saint John
Kansas Catholic Church I'm going to be
talking about sacred art for a sacred
Arts Guild there I will also be talking
the next day on Sunday after the church
service at their lunch that they have
it's gonna be a bit more informal
talking about you know how to include
symbolism and kind of the symbolic life
in in family life so so that's gonna
happen there I also mentioned that I'm
gonna be at Saint T cons now a lot of
people have been writing the asking me
for details on that and I kind of spoke
too quickly and then I checked with the
people organizing the event the event is
only for the seminarians the seminarians
at st. econ's but also the other
seminarians at st. glads and the other
Orthodox seminaries around
Holy Cross and so so what's gonna happen
is the priest father John who's
responsible for for the for a lot of the
seminary he he under he saw that some
people wanted to come that aren't from
the seminary and so what we're gonna do
is after liturgy on Sunday morning which
is going to be the 3rd of November I
will be doing some I will do like a
little bit of speaking and take some
questions so if you do want to come to
Santa cons in in Pennsylvania you can do
that try to get there maybe come to
liturgy and then after liturgy I'll be
doing a little bit of speaking so yeah
so that's it for the that's it for the
announcements oh yeah one last
announcement the the last video I did I
kind of knew that it was going to stir a
lot of a lot of stuff the video about
there is only
there is no literal meaning obviously I
hope some of you understood that I was
using a bit of a provocative title and
speaking very provocatively once again I
want to reiterate that I am not implying
that that that everything is just just
that it's not referring to events that
the Bible isn't speaking about events of
course I believe that it is of course I
believe the resurrection is real and I
just wanted to say one thing I one of
the few of the comments on the YouTube
of that video were we're very thoughtful
and we're talking about how it seems
like in my last videos I have been
becoming a bit more arrogant and let's
say my my tone is is becoming unpleasant
and and I don't remember the name of the
person who wrote that comment but I want
to thank you because it's something that
I've been kind of feeling in myself that
hadn't been totally understood in my
mind yet but I could feel and reading
that comment has helped me hopefully
I'll be able to tone it down a bit and
and do less less criticizing of others
and more trying to present beauty and
truth and the things that excite me
which is the reason why I started making
these videos in the first place so
hopefully I will be able to do that and
if I'm not able to do that guys really
call me out in the YouTube comments
I usually try to pay attention to the
first few days of the YouTube comments
usually that's when I feel like the most
engaged people are writing and then
after a few day then I stop because then
all that then a lot of the madness
appears on now some of my videos that
propaganda video has like 300 I don't
know 350,000 years or whatever 300,000
views and and now almost all the
comments on that video are are
horrendous
so anyways alright so so I'm going to
start with the as usual what I'm going
to do is I'm going to start with the
patron questions just remind you guys
for people who are giving at the ten
dollar level I opened up the possibility
of asking questions in advance and then
after that I will go to super chats we
have
as usual two moderators Jakob Russell
and Kristian Chad who I trust completely
so don't don't annoy them because yeah
you won't get any sympathy for me if
they if they remove your your comments
or your super chats if you write stupid
stuff alright so here we go I'm gonna
start with my website okay alright so
Jimmy D thing says I'm curious how you
feel about Philip Pullman's his dark
materials series they're pretty clearly
an inversion of Milton's Paradise Lost
so it's on brand for something for you
to explain to us who can see there's
something to be seen there that perhaps
we have trouble seeing or finding the
words to explain to ourselves the reason
I ask is because HBO is about to start
airing a new series depicting these
books and I have a feeling they're going
to be popular I have not read the books
I know about them I know a little bit
about the story and about the premises
and I mean I don't want to speak too
much because like I said I haven't read
them but for sure the notion that
someone would put out a book that would
take paradise lost' premise and let's
say invert it or show that in fact the
the Satan character is is right and that
the Satan character is his on the right
track or that eating the Apple is right
that is completely in line with the
modern way of thinking you know that
sometimes when I listen to people like
another shift is some of the more
explicit Satanists you know I realized
that they're pretty smart because they
understand that the way that let's say
even someone like Anton LaVey for
example that his Satanism is basically
just modern culture he understands that
a lot of modern culture is is and then
is upside down is an inversion and is in
a certain manner satanic you can kind of
sympathize the things that we have to
always be able to explore thoughts and
not just reacted with a knee-jerk
reaction we have to be able to
understand why someone would view the
eating of the fruit in the garden as be
sympathetic to that because the question
is why is it a problem that we eat that
we know good and evil you know the the
the snake said you know this is that
this is this is it's it's a big it's a
big thing it's something to think about
and I've actually seen I've actually
seen people that I care about I've seen
Jordan Peterson seem to suggest that he
thinks that eating the fruit in the
garden was was good now the the
Christian answer the right Christian
answer in my opinion is the one which is
given by st. Irenaeus and the one which
is given by Senate from the Syrian which
is that God would have given the fruit
to Adam and Eve if only they had they
had obeyed him in humility that is if
they had understood their place in the
hierarchy of being then ultimately God
would have given them the fruit of the
of the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil as they are accessing the that the
fruit of the tree of life and so but
because they did so in arrogance and by
elevating themselves trying to elevate
themselves into into this hierarchy of
being then oak seeing the knowledge of
good and evil made them fear what they
saw above them made them afraid of
actually seeing the glory of God that's
why they cover themselves they're hiding
themselves because by seeing the
knowledge of good and evil and doing it
in this trying to lift yourself up of a
sudden you're blinded by the let's say
the glory of that which is above but God
what God wanted was for Adam and Eve to
- to understand where they were and then
God was to bring them up towards his
glory that was the purpose of creation
in the first place and in the end God is
going to do that anyways and that's what
the Incarnation is and there's a there's
a kind of a weird joke in in the Genesis
story which is that the the serpent told
Adam and Eve God told Adam and Eve if
you eat the fruit you will
I the serpent said if you eat the fruit
then you will become like God and what
happened in the end is that both
happened is is what happened in the end
is Christ and the the conclusion of
eating the fruit of the tree of good and
evil is that he who died with humility
he who accepted death voluntarily was
the one who was God and so it all comes
together in the end in the story like I
keep telling guys the biblical story is
is is there's no limit to where it goes
all right so that's too much talking for
a book I haven't read about but uh maybe
I mean if if the series is good maybe
I'll I'll watch it and I'll do some some
some comics you might have noticed that
I haven't been doing some movie comments
in the last few months and the reason is
very simple is because I'm just tired of
the copyright thing I got a copyright
strike for my video on spirited away and
as you know on YouTube if you get three
copyright strikes you're out your
YouTube channel can be deleted and some
controversial YouTube channels have been
deleted through the use of copyright and
so I really I'm very nervous about going
in that direction I've also had on every
single one of my videos about about that
that are doing movie interpretations
I've had some kind of copyright problem
and I've had to to protest to fight it
and then finally most of them were
restored some of them are still blocked
in some parts of the of the world but
the spirited away one was taken down and
was I got a strike so I'm not I'm not
sure that it's I'm not totally sure it's
worth it unless you guys really rail and
tell me that that's what I should be
doing I feel like at least for now a lot
of this stuff I'm talking about talk
about stories talking about this
different stuff has been has been has
been better maybe I could make some
movie interpretations that would be less
video intense and maybe just show some
stills from the movies something like
that in order to avoid the copyright
problem but uh yeah
so I but I am putting all my stuff up on
bit on the [ __ ] shoot and on D tube so
if you want to follow me there please go
ahead and follow me all right here we go
so david Flores I can always I can
always count on David to ask a good
question so let's see so why are ancient
evil monsters villains principalities so
much more fearsome and powerful and
stories is it related to the experience
said evil creature or is it something
about forgotten knowledge about it not
sure I totally understand your question
like are you asking are you asking are
you asking why they're more fearsome in
stories than let's say in our in our
experience of them like is that what you
mean David I'm watching the chat so you
need to answer me alright so let me try
to answer if David's not gonna give me
give me more as opposed to like new evil
well okay so one of the things okay so
one of the things that a lot of stories
one of the things that a lot of the
stories do is that they condense things
into into an image which is which is
beyond reference to particular time so
for example like there's nothing scarier
let's say in terms of fearsome and
powerful there's nothing more fearsome
or powerful than a you know an f-18
fighter that is coming towards your
village there there's absolutely nothing
more fearful than a nuclear weapon or a
or a helicopter drop dropping napalm
napalm on some village in the jungle
like there is nothing in the ancient
world that is more terrifying than that
now so so the so modern monsters are in
the some manner the equivalent or
scarier freakier than any monster that
exists in the ancient times now in terms
of in terms of monsters not in the not
in the sense that I usually talk about
it let just in terms
ambiguity but mothers in the sense of
the big thing that's gonna come and eat
you now the reason why in stories we
usually will use tropes that are more
traditional like a you know a giant
beast or a you know a blood sucking
thing or a man-eating monster for sure
man-eating is one of the one of the the
best images that you can get of a
monster fire-breathing dragon all this
stuff is because it it connects all the
levels together right it can still it
can still bring about the image of the
modern evil but it's not so dependent on
contemporary references and so it's
going to connect to a very very deep
deep intuitive understanding of what the
monster is you know like that beast and
the forest it's going to eat you so I
think that that's what that's why let's
say the the monster is that in stories
look more powerful in terms of their the
fact that they are they also one of the
things that they do is that they they'll
usually have a character which is
extremely powerful and extremely evil
and extremely all of this and that
character has powers that he can you
know you know that in like Voldemort for
example so Voldemort is is the person
doing the magic he's also the scary
freaky character he's terrifying all of
this now because when they're when a
when a helicopter drops napalm on a
village the person behind that or if a
drone you know blows up some some you
know some pharmaceutical building in the
Middle East you know the person behind
the drone is somewhere in America and
the person who's actually controlling
the videogame drone is not even the
person who's willing that the wheel
comes from somewhere else and so it's
hard to represent that so that
everything comes together but if you
want to represent it so that everything
comes together then you have the evil
sorcerer who's doing it himself right
who's standing there and he's shooting
electric he's shooting electricity out
of his fingers or whatever but there's
no difference in terms of the
the insanity in terms of the devastation
that we have the same thing today we
have works today
the monsters today that the big bad
monsters today they can do way more
damage than any monster in the history
of the world so so you know you just
look at look at look at if you have no I
don't know if you guys saw that video
that there was showing up drone which
was going through the city of Damascus
it's like my goodness
Godzilla went through there you know
that's what it looks like so alright
okay so Pat Shire asks hello Jonathan I
recently talked with evangelicals who
are running a panel called
are you going to help who panel are you
going to help signs on my campus and
they seemed anxious when I said I'm
going to the Catholic Church because
you're going to hell there Pat there are
two lessons for this that I've picked up
on one the faith works issue and two
liturgy Catholic hierarchies I don't
know much about Luther's solafeet a
argument but as far as liturgy goes I
tried to Det I tried to demonstrate that
ritual is natural but they talked about
literally almost as if it is
brainwashing little guidance would be
greatly appreciated alright
so psi stick back into the Catholic
Church and it's and feels like it is
moving in an amazing direction thank you
again for all your wisdom so so Pat I
mean there are some people that won't be
convinced there's there's some people I
mean there is something to say for
throwing pearls as Christ said so you
just be careful not to get into ruts
where you start arguing with people that
are not gonna change their mind if you
notice that I don't get into debates or
I try not to get into debates online or
on on social media it's because I feel
like it's useless so so try to be
attentive to whether or not it's useful
or useless to to argue with these people
but I would I would say that the best
thing to do is to point out the rituals
that they're engaged in so for example
if liturgy is brainwashing
the question would be like what is
singing hymns why do you sing
why does everybody sing hymns at the
same time
that could also be seen in the same
logic it could be seen as a form of
brainwashing why you know so so one of
the things that that somehow the the
disjunction and a lot of people's thing
is that they they think they say that
prayer should always be extra print
extemporaneous that prayer should always
be improvised that even saying the
Lord's Prayer is evil but then they sing
songs that were written in the sixteenth
century and so it's like you know the
the best thing to do is to maybe try to
point out some of their own cognitive
dissonance but like I said just be
careful not to get into arguments and
not to let yourself go to the arrogance
that I myself let myself go to sometimes
so alright so Keenan Cronin asks what
advice would you give to a Christian who
holds personal beliefs that are at odds
with the church at large for example
believing that homosexuality may not be
sinful with your answer change depending
on the church who are part of example
Roman Catholic Eastern Orthodox Baptist
etc so I would say that in terms of that
I mean if you want me to answer that
specific question I would say that the
answer should not change based on the
denominations you mentioned there are
denominations which we call liberal
denominations or you know mainstream
mainline Protestants you would call them
who have changed the way that the church
has the church is teaching on that
question but at least officially the the
dent denominations you mentioned have
not changed their thinking on that and
so the question is what would you do if
you hold personal beliefs that are at
odds with the church I would say that
the best thing to do is to just walk
humbly step-by-step and to
do not pretend to not to not lie to
yourself to not lie to others about what
you believe in which you think but also
not to try to change things that is the
biggest problem is that we all all of us
sometimes will have some thoughts or
some some thinking that we think you
know this thing I'm not so sure about
this I'm not so sure about that
and I think the best thing to do is to
just walk slowly and and walk slowly and
pay attention listen try to learn and
try not to use the church as a as a
platform to advance your opinions but I
think that I think that it's normal for
most people especially on in terms of
secondary questions like that I mean
there's a difference between doctrinal
questions and then moral questions not
that is it isn't important it is
important but I would say that that's
the best thing to do in the second thing
I would say is to talk to the authority
you are part of that of the church apart
of talk to your priest talk to your talk
to your pastor talk to you know end and
end and they they will hopefully they
will be a guide to help you through your
questions to help you through your your
relief to help you through whatever it
is you're struggling with um hopefully
that's the case sometimes it's not I'm
sorry when that happens but uh what I
would say to to be honest and humble
those are the best things the best way
to go if you're honest and arrogant then
then that's the doesn't help because
then it looks like you're just trying to
change everything to fit your own
personal opinion if you're humble but
you're lying that's not good for your
soul so that's the best way that's the
best thing I would say to do all right
all right so Jesse Blaney asked hi
Jonathan hopefully these two so we've
got two questions are ya
so first quarter our less heavy
questions this round I am wondering if
you have explained the icon that you use
in
website and YouTube thumbnail no I've
never I've never explained it in a video
maybe it's because I just think it's
it's self-evident what it is but I've
had several requests to to explain the
the image that I use it is an image from
a German missile I forget the name of
the the actual book it's a it's a
medieval Western image and it represents
the six days of creation and it
represents the creation of Eve and so if
you look at if you look at the circle
you'll see that it says day 1 day 2 day
3 in Latin at the different at the
different days and there are other
inscriptions as well to describe what is
happening and then in the center you
have Eve who is asleep and you have Adam
that is asleep and Eve that is coming
out of Adam and you know it's it's I
chose that for many reasons first of all
because of the six days were very
beautifully represented in this
beautiful thing in the creation of man
represented in the center but I also
represented it because of the creation
of Eve as you probably noticed a lot of
my efforts have been to talk about
feminine symbolism in in kind of
critiquing some of the way that it's
presented in modern world but also
trying to give a beautiful and powerful
alternative to to what is being
presented in our culture and so that is
also one of the reasons why I chose that
image but if you guys want maybe I can
make a video where I can actually have
it on and you know the image and then go
through the days maybe do a little bit
of the symbolism of the days as well
maybe something like that
alright so Jesse also asks in your last
video on rituals I think I heard you
make a reference between rebellion and a
form of cultural appropriation the link
had to do with youth pastors and what
they dress like what do you oh yeah okay
what do you believe is the diving line
that separates honor
and the dividing line that separates
honor and dishonor another way the
question might be what is a guiding
principle for Christian encountering
forms of cultural appropriation so I
don't think that my problem was cultural
appropriation in terms of the youth
pastor it was mostly the desire to to
use the tropes of inform being informal
use the tropes use the tropes of of kind
of punk rock culture or rock-and-roll
culture you know the certain imagery
that is very tip if I'd that we know we
can recognize it we know what it means
when somebody dresses like that we know
what it means when somebody acts like
that and then so the youth type youth
type pastor will take on those tropes in
order to to show some kinship with
modern culture and I think what I was
criticizing was that now in terms of
honor and dishonor I would say that the
thing about honor and dishonor is that
it's all about situation everything is
about situation that it's all how can I
say this there's nothing that's wrong in
itself there's nothing wrong with
wearing ripped jeans dude I wear ripped
jeans when I'm working it's not a
problem I wear t-shirts and I wear you
know and I and I'm sloppy and but I'm in
but the workshop and I'm working ain't
no and if I go to the beach I wear a
bathing suit and a t-shirt then I take
my t-shirt off and I go into the water
and so it's but I don't I won't go to
church like that and I and I won't go to
the store like that and so it's it's
it's the the line is all about context
it's like everything is about being in
the right place you know everything is
good if it's in the right place there's
nothing that is bad in itself the
problem with the youth pastor who
dresses like a rock star and then wants
to pretend like like he's being informal
and in improvising and cool but he's
he's standing there in front of
everybody and every
attention is on that person and so he
should be he should be modeling a center
rather than modeling the periphery as
you're speaking to him but like I said
there's nothing wrong with the with the
periphery if you see a beggar who's
dressed like that guy in in who's
standing on the stage in some you know
in some church where he's all he's all
messy and has messy hair if you see a
beggar like that you should have mercy
on that beggar and you should help him
out it's like it just depends on where
where things are I hope that answers
that all right all right so david Flores
asks another question he says my next
question is about your literal meaning
video and I'm afraid coz all right as I
understand it when people are talking
about literal meaning they want to get
to the bottom of things a definition of
reality of what is true I agree with you
about biased purpose and meaning always
affecting the objective or literal
meaning how do we come to know what is
true if all we have is subjectivity I
think your response is going to be
hierarchy all right you already know my
answer David and it is how how do we use
to measure how true something is how do
we use evaluate its place in the
hierarchy of truth so okay so the the
biggest the biggest thing the biggest
thing that I maybe I want to emphasize
on maybe adding a little more to the to
the literal meaning video is that what
I'm trying to point you guys to know
what I'm trying to get you to see is
that stability of something is not found
in the phenomena it's not found below
it's not found it's found above the
stability is held from above you could
say this way you could say that the
something is true to the measure in
which it is in Christ right that's a way
to say this it is very Christian but
it's not arbitrary it's not just just
not just saying that it's that as things
are attached to their Logie to the to
the logos which is their essence their
purpose the reason why we notice them in
the first place
that that as those things let's say Co
here in this hierarchy ultimately with
what it's showing is how they're
attached to to to Christ and so it's not
it's not that like the idea an idea the
idea of something objective is it's so
interesting like if you look at if you
look at at the time like if you look at
the Greek philosophers if you look at
the ancients for them that which was
stable and objective was math that is
the most stable and objective thing not
the phenomena the phenomenons are
fleeting in the their their changing and
they move math is what it's tables for
somehow some reason people have been
able to I don't totally get it they've
been able to conflate them together that
somehow math and phenomenas are related
maybe because people use math to measure
phenomena but those two things are not
the same anyways I don't want to go too
much into this maybe I will make a video
a follow-up video on that and look at
some of the better questions that came
up in the in the YouTube the YouTube
comments cuz some of them are good some
of them I think asking questions I think
I think point to some dangers that could
be if if what I'm saying is
misunderstood what dangers that could
entail um but I'm not definitely not
saying that everything is subjective
that is for sure alright
okay so Diaz Bru asks hi Jonathan I'm
wondering if you could talk a bit about
the symbolism of musical instruments in
my tears book he talks about them as the
cosmic axial which makes the world the
world pointlessly turned and danced and
implements of recreation renewal
reawakening and even resurrection can
you help me understand this from an
orthodox perspective since musical
instruments are not used in the liturgy
or in sacred space what is their proper
or highest possible place in the
hierarchy outside the narthex
as a call to prayer like the taça
letting people know the time
know what chipping away at his art I'm
hoping there is a way to use them to
wake up some piece what we do have with
the we have instruments in your other
lecture if you have bells that is for
sure
um and the you could say that the the
the voice or the singing voice in the
church in the Orthodox Church has been a
way to bring this notion of this notion
of turning you could say this notion of
pattern to its highest level because the
musical instrument has a form of
externality it's a it's a garment of
skin and you can see that in Genesis
because the musical instruments are are
come from Cain's lineage and so so that
so there are these garments of skin and
so from an Orthodox perspective I mean
musical instruments are fine like I said
they're fine outside the church and
there's nothing wrong with with musical
instruments and I think that music has a
capacity to go very deep in terms of our
intuitions in terms of our perception
intuitive perception of patterns and so
music is very important I don't I don't
totally understand music I think I've
mentioned that you guys before I don't
totally understand music but if you want
to see a very simple image of what when
material about how musical instruments
are an image of recreation renewal and
resurrection just look at the icon of
the Last Judgement and there you will
see angels playing trumpets and you will
see you know this image of Saint Gabriel
calling the dead out through the use of
a trumpet and so and so there's there's
a very powerful image of what Matthew is
talking about of how the the musical
instrument can be used as a as a as a
call to awake
all right so so Jacob our moderator
asked this for someone else for Dionysus
who frequents our discord group as you
know there is maybe you don't know but
there is a symbolic world discord group
that I don't go on many very often just
because of my because I don't have a lot
of time but it seems like it's not super
active but it's there if you're really
interested in it the best would be to go
in the Facebook group and talk to to
Jacob I think he holds the keys to that
okay so Dionysus says this is for my
video on rituals what you pointed out
regarding rituals is very true but I
believe attention needs to be directed
on the pitfalls of ritualistic behavior
for example emotional conditioning
superstitious behavior and thought
fanatical belief in the exclusivity of
rituals of when faith has the correct
rituals confusion between the container
and the content suitability of certain
rituals for the present time place and
people acceptable of taking part and
formalized rituals because of these in
my very in my view very important issues
would love to hear your thoughts on the
subject Thanks I thought this all right
so um I greet I agree that there's such
a thing as an empty ritual obviously
there there's always such a thing as an
empty form or an empty exterior form um
that is of course why Christ is always
talking about hypocrisy
you know what Christ wants is not you
when people see Christ as the
revolutionary who wants to remove the
forms you're gonna run into problems
because there are many place where he
affirmed them although there are there
are also many places where he criticizes
them the best way to understand it is
that what Christ wants is for a unity of
logos with the world he wants what he is
he wants the unity of the spiritual and
the material physical particular
together and so that is the best ritual
the the ritual of course ultimately we
we try to both engage
the outer form while having disposed
ourselves in terms of the inner form now
now I think that I think in terms of
Christianity I would say that for sure
baptism and communion especially are two
rituals which I think are are in are not
temporal I think are not are not they're
so basic the idea of eating the idea of
bathing or going down into the into
death down into water and coming out
those rituals really they they they are
they are universal they don't they're
not time specific or culture specific in
terms of of communion it's a little
cultural specific because obviously
bread and wine is not something which is
universal but it does become universal
especially for us for sure it's not it's
not a problem because bread and wine is
part of our life we all know what bread
and wine is we all we all still eat
bread and wine except for except for all
the carnivores out there you can make an
exception for communion I'm sure and so
until I would say that I would say that
saying that you don't want to be
involved in ritual is a little bit naive
because like I said ritual is an
inevitable part of life and so if you
are not aware of the rituals you are
part of you will be engaging in rituals
that you're not aware of you will be
become a slave to bad habits to ritual
behavior that that will be there despite
yourself and so it is best to understand
that ritual is inevitable and then
engage in ritual with your whole heart
like engage in the Christian ritual with
your ear as much as you can with your
entire being and that's why you know
like in the Orthodox Church you know
you're supposed to supposed to go to
confession you you have to have some
kind of prayer life you you have some
accountability
- to going to communion you can't just
you don't just go just can't just go up
go like this if you do that you are you
are breaking what's supposed to happen
you're you're supposed to have some kind
of spiritual life someone following you
someone helping you along so that the
ritual doesn't become just an empty form
all right okay so let's move to
subscribe star all right okay
so mmm Nicola asks hi Jonathan
I've been puzzling over the question of
sexuality for years on March 2017 in
Toronto you broach the topic of
metaphysics of sex and how sex can be
and should be used to strive towards God
it sounds beautiful I would love to be
all-in with sex but I'm still very
scared of making kids with my soon-to-be
wife because of our very troublesome
finances we both want kids but even
making ends meet with a potential kid
would not be possible on current income
let alone saving a bit for rainy days
you have any advice to give on this
topic ah Nicola I have to tell you that
I totally disagree with you completely
on the way that you're perceiving this
the idea that kids are expensive is
something that advertisers want you to
believe or something I don't know the if
you if you have first of all if you have
a if you have a child hopefully your
wife will breastfeed that child yes
there are the cost of diapers you can
have we are first kids we had washable
diapers and there are always there are
always people out there to help those
who have kids and so if your if your
only reason for not having kids is
financial then I would say that just
look around you and you will find all
this type of community help you can find
all these things secondhand you know you
almost everything you can find second
because people have kids and then they
get rid of this stuff that they had with
kids and they all have one or two kids
anyways so all this stuff baby stuff you
can find on on the second-hand pages um
I would say that I would say that your I
would say that your reason is not it's
not the right reason I understand why
society's pressuring you to think that
and to to see the world that way but you
know people have been having children
for ever since human beings exist and in
all kinds of situation and you will see
that if you have a child and you invest
yourself in that child you will
experience joy and you will experience a
kind of maturation that you can't even
understand until it happens I can't
explain to you what having a child does
to you you know as a man what it does to
you
because all of a sudden you're the
provider and that will that will knock
some sense into you it will make you
change your priorities if you're just a
little bit sensitive and a little bit
attentive to your child and you don't
fight the natural tendency you have to
want to to to to take care of things
into to be a provider it's the best
thing that can happen to you all right
so Christian Chad says our other
moderator so hi Jonathan do you think we
can ever return to a version of the
medieval ancient world wow man
for example a world with buffer zones
between ideas identities in places a
world where authority was rare but
brutal and most of life was in the shade
instead of constant surveillance if we
cannot return to it what is the new
direction we should take I don't
sorry I don't have a good answer for you
there Christian I I don't think I don't
think that at least not in the
foreseeable future that that's going to
happen
yeah I don't know what to say decide
that for sure the way that things are
going now can't go on forever but uh but
I don't see that I don't see it us
returning to the ancient world or that
the type of structure that you described
least not in the short term so what can
we do is I think that we have to create
small spaces we have to create remnants
of subtle existence remnants of
community remnants of you know that's
what like a family is awesome because
you can you can do that you can have a
family which is which is both that has a
form of strictness in terms of
expectation but also has love and
compassion and understanding for
aberrations and for weirdness
all the while remaining keeping a line
on what's acceptable and what is not so
you can do that in a family so I would
say have a family and try to find
like-minded families already and you
know I find a church find a find a good
church that is going to be able to to
support you in that vision so Christian
also asked hi Jonathan have you read
anything by Nassim Taleb his writing on
religion helped me get over my early
atheist phase of religion is unreason
religion is unreasonable I also find his
idea of Christ having skin in the game
and interesting explanation of the
Trinity um I haven't really read
anything by him for some reason he
follows me on Twitter I don't know what
how that happened
he at least his behavior and Twitter is
extremely is really extreme I'm really
surprised at how aggressive he is and
how he just kind of goes after people
and caused everybody frauds and
everybody and everybody charlatans and
everything so I don't quite know I don't
kind of what to think like I you know it
doesn't give me the desire to read his
his stuff but maybe I should you know
this idea of skin in the game is for
sure a good idea in terms of of
understanding
what of understanding why people act and
understanding you know motivation
alright yeah I always say if you want if
you want people to be involved in
something don't give them everything ask
something of them it's like that'll make
them involved they have if they they
they've actually put their own sweat
that's one of the reasons why people
have to give money at church it's not
you know if you had if you had like a
billionaire in your church and they and
and he could finance everything in your
church you should still give money at
church because when you give money to
church oh my goodness it changes your
perception of your place there you feel
like you're part of it you feel like
you're your this is yours like it you've
got skin in the game so maybe I should
read this thing
alright hi Jonathan what are your
thoughts on the idea of received visions
I'm a visual artist and often have ideas
come to me fully formed as it's as if a
cartoon light bulb turned on above my
head except it's illuminating a fully
rendered image sometimes scenes
containing imagery with deep symbolic
meaning some that I've told about this
experience say these are visions but I'm
struggling with the term because it
seems too high Oh while calling them
pictures seems too low thank you for
your time I appreciate your perspective
I agree that I mean there's I don't have
a problem with having visions I think
that people can be connected and can
people are not everybody but a lot of
people are like tuning forks and they
can catch some patterns they can kind of
catch them and see them or they they can
they can engage them or they can
manifest themselves to to them for sure
so so for example in in the Orthodox
tradition visions are definitely part of
the tradition there are many stories of
visions Saints having visions sometimes
whole churches having visions all of
these things are possible but for at the
same time the fathers are always warning
us to be wary of visions and to be
careful
for several reasons one is that they can
make us boastful second of all is that
when you when you're like a tuning fork
and you it's it's it's like how can I
explain it it's like so it's like you
put out your antenna and you can get
these visions but did it's not clear all
the time what it is that you're catching
sometimes you might not be catching the
best stuff and so that's why you have to
be careful and if you look at the if you
look at the church fathers whence they
once they develop their spiritual
capacity you would say once they kind of
develop their noose they're
higher-capacity
they start to have they start to see
angels you know they have visions of
heavenly things but then they also have
visions of demons and they have visions
of demons present proof pretending to be
angels and they have all this wild stuff
that happens to them sometimes the the
biggest saint you know the stories of
monks that spent their whole life prayer
praying and they you know some some
divine vision takes them to the top of a
mountain and and when they get there
they realize that it's like some demon
who's who's snickering in and trying to
get him to become prideful so I would
say that I would say that to discern the
vision is something that should happen
hopefully you're a part of some church
hopefully you're part of some you're
part of a tradition where you can ask
advice about that if not then I don't
know man it's tough it's tough because
you know it's the same with the whole
psychedelic thing it's like I don't know
I've never taken psychedelics but if
it's true that psychedelics somehow can
open up that antenna where you can all
of a sudden let's say perceive patterns
and perceive beings that are not
physical that you can suddenly see them
in terms in your mind or in your I don't
know whatever that you can perceive them
in a different manner you know it's like
man just because you take a pill like
you haven't at all works on being able
to discern the patterns like you would
you be able to tell the difference
between an angel of light and the
as an angel of light like I don't know
because I don't know I don't know so I
would say just I would say don't don't
think that it's that it's not
necessarily just an illusion but I would
just say to to just stay trying to stay
humble about it and to try to discern
what it is that you're perceiving all
right
so we're moving to patreon we just see
cuz sometimes people write these last
many questions and I haven't like
refreshed because I don't I don't
necessarily refresh the question
sometimes I might miss something all
right okay so let's move to patreon
all right so Robert Smits asks can you
discuss the symbolism of shopping malls
their decline seems almost inevitable
given that they have no unified purpose
like a set of organs which doesn't form
a body well my my theory about shopping
malls I met I mentioned this in a few
talks is that they're kind of like the
last ditch effort at communion they you
know that size if in a normal world in
in the normal world the church would be
that the place of communion where
everybody kind of comes together in the
right in the right direction then
there's also the political space where
that would happen let's say a town
square then there's also and then the
like today the third place would be the
market you know and so the shopping mall
is is kind of like the last version of
that in terms of creating a space where
people can come together but to buy
stuff so it's kind of like a market but
because because the church is going away
and because the let's say the public
square is going away then the shopping
mall has for a while kind of took on
this
kind of monstrous or gigantic space and
so I think like you said I think you're
right that they're gonna go away because
once the the once the highest thing
starts to degrade then you don't see it
at first but the things start to degrade
all down the hierarchy and so you you
think that no it's it's the joke it's
like you think that you know when the
King when the you you think that you
think when the king displaces the the
priesthood you know he thinks that aha
now I've displaced that all those
pestering people telling me what's right
and wrong
he takes the power but then you know
he's got the bourgeoisie right there
waiting to come and get him and when
that happens they're like aha we finally
got rid of this political [ __ ] now we
can do what you want like there's other
stuff lower stuff still on the bottom
that are gonna come up and devour you so
yeah that's what's happening that's
what's happening with the shopping malls
so so norm called and asked why does
Jesus continually perform miracles in
the Gospels but then immediately tell
those he heals not to say anything about
it there's a few things I've been
thinking about this very long time I
don't think I totally have the answer
for this but I will give you my little
tidbits there's a mystery related to the
idea of the secret it's as if this is
hard to understand because it's as if
the center has to be hidden the center
has to be secret for the world to lay
itself out properly you'd think you'd
think let's say in terms if you were
just using reason you'd think well with
the center have to be visible like
because that's the thing we're all
turned towards like that's the origin of
everything but but but because the
center is actually not the thing it's
like because the center is the cause
inside or it's a hidden hidden pearl
it's it's not that you know it's not the
actual thing then it has to be hidden
because it's the intention it's the
logos it's the spirit of something you
know it's not visible anyways so there
seems to be something about that in the
fact that Christ is asking to hide his
his his works at the beginning and then
it's like it's like a seed it's like
Christ is planting the seed all the way
through the story of the gospel and at
first it's like hidden and then it has
to die and then it becomes then it feels
the world something like that so I don't
know if I'm I don't know if this is
making sense you guys but uh to me that
is the that is the the best
understanding I've had of that all right
so Norma Conte also asked can you please
discuss the symbolism of Galatians 2:20
particularly the idea of having been
crucified with Christ and that Christ
now lives in him I've been crucified
with Christ and I no longer live but
Christ lives in me the life I now live
in the body I live by faith in the Son
of God who loved me and gave himself for
me so Noir is is did he yeah they're
always bringing that up because I
because I mentioned that in in the video
or in the comments in my last video
about literal truth when I talk about
st. Paul I think I mentioned that in a
comment um so what is the symbolism of
that the symbolism the symbolism of that
is Christ is showing us the source of
reality Christ is exemplifying the way
in which the world actually works he is
the he is the the source he is the the
finality of everything and so the idea
is that
ultimately we want to all be that we
want to participate in Christ to
participate to participate in Christ to
be crucified with Christ is to enter
into the holy of Holy's it is to enter
into the garden it is to to to eat both
the fruit of the knowledge of good and
evil and the fruit of the the fruit of
the tree of life all of that together
and so we are meant to become little
Christ that's what the word Christian
means the word Christian just means
little Christ that's what we're meant to
be and so Paul is expressing how he is
participating how he is participating in
Christ and how he has given himself
completely to Christ and so it's not him
who lives
it's Christ who lives in him and you
could say that ultimately it's also at
the same time the fullness of who he is
right
and so by living that life he has also
reached the totality of what he can be
you know yeah this is mysterious stuff
guys so I don't know if I can say any
more about that so anjo Terpstra asks
how do you regard the Gospel of Thomas
in your worldview um how do I regard it
I mean there are some good things in the
Gospel of Thomas I think there's some
things that are interesting there are
some some things that are radical some
of the statements are so similar to the
to the the regular Gospels that it's
it's as if it's just the the gospel and
then there are a few things that are
weird and a few things that are kind of
off off-key but I mean I don't I don't
mind these ex I don't mind a lot of
these books
telling people I don't mind if you read
all these weird books that have been
found you know sometimes it can make you
ask questions that you wouldn't have
asked it can provoke some thought that
you wouldn't have thought of I would I
always just tell people to just bring it
back to bring it back to the Father to
bring it back to the church like don't
you can you can look at things in the
periphery of your vision you know and
and and get something from it you don't
have to bring it into your heart like so
I think that's not like the Gospel
Thomas that you know the book could you
believe all these books that that were
kind of found you know the this kind of
return of the The Book of Enoch that
everybody thought had was gone forever
you know I think is useful I think some
of that is useful and then some of it is
not and the I mean and we know what the
the the measuring stick is it's the
stick read it's the it's the Church
Fathers it's you know it's the tradition
of the church so that's how I see it all
right so Elina t asked can you explain
the concept of aerial tole houses in
orthodoxy my goodness guys serious you
know that the total houses in orthodoxy
is the reason why I barely post on
Facebook and on Twitter anymore because
I kind of let myself go on that subject
and got emotionally involved
so the aerial tour houses in orthodoxy
is a tradition which is not what we call
a theologian on that is it is a supplies
tradition it has not been proved by any
council by any directly by anybody but
it's it's a pious tradition which seems
to also have hmm have some pre-christian
sources some pagan sources involved in
the way it's formulated in the way that
it's presented and it's basically the
idea that after you die you ascend these
you ascend and
with you is an angel entity many other
angel on your right shoulder a demon on
your left shoulder and then your
ascending and as you reach the total
houses the demon it'll accuse you and of
the sin let's say each tall house is
like a sin and the demon will accuse you
and the angel will kind of help you and
you have to you have to kind of pay the
toll you have to prove that you can move
to the next station and you know it it
sounds like it's very it sounds very
technical when you look at it in terms
of it you have to you have to have these
prayers and you have to have sometimes
the prayer of the saint or the prayer of
this or that and so we have to be
careful not to take it we have to be
careful we take it I think the best case
scenario with the with the toll houses
is this notion of ontological hierarchy
which exists and which exists now it
doesn't just exist in the in after death
it's happening now who keep telling
people you're going through the total
houses now not just after you die but
everything that you you you represent
after death is like a it's like a like a
projection into totality of your life so
it's like what you do now is represented
symbolically in these tall houses that
are after death that you ascend and that
you you you have to that you can ascend
but you can also descend and so one of
the things it does is one of the dangers
of it is of course to get too caught up
in the in the details of it and to see
it as this this just this technical
thing that you have to have so many
prayers and you have to have so many
things and you have to do that like that
is I don't think that's the right way to
understand it but if you can understand
it as just this basic notion of a
hierarchy that you're ascending and that
the prayers of the Saints and the
prayers of those around you helps you
and that the the good you do and you
know all these things are part of this
ascent of this hierarchy then it doesn't
it doesn't really bother me that much
and what
but it also does is that it you need
this ontological hierarchy because and
that's also one of the reasons why
Catholics at purgatory purgatory is the
same has the same problems as as toll
houses in terms of if you take it if you
should get to cut up in the details and
the technical aspects of purgatory and
all these years and whatever and and
everything it's it's that's problematic
but if you understand it that if you
understand it as the notion that there
has to be transformation for you to come
into the life of God you know that it's
not just that you believe these things
and that you're with God it's like I
don't even know what that would mean
it's like I'm in heaven die and go to
heaven like that kind of thinking that
is that is not useful it because you
have to in order for you to go to heaven
in order for you to ascend the higher
either spiritual hierarchy you have to
transform into what you were where
you're going you have to become the
level that you're at and so it's not
just a it's not just this this arbitrary
thing that it's like you if you you
believe something you die and you all of
a sudden you're with God if you're with
God it means you're becoming like God
you can't you can't just be with God
it's like I hope this makes sense but it
is very controversial in the church and
there's some people that are totally
forward who take everything like like
this is exactly the description of what
what happens after death there are other
people who are completely against it who
thinking that it's just paganism that is
coming to the church and there are
people who are in between I would say
that I'm somewhere in between but I try
not to emphasize that stuff because yeah
but I do it besides the hierarchy though
this idea of a of an ontological
hierarchy of transformation alright so
drew me man asked Plato or Aristotle
what do you think
yeah it's obvious that I'm more of a
plainness but I also I also think that I
think that someone like st. Maximus has
been able to take the best of Plato and
the best of air
startled and really filtered out the
stuff that needs to be filtered out and
brought it into a Christian vision so so
for example like really say Maximus and
and kind of the Christian cosmologists
they really have this idea that yes
there are these essences but the
essences only exist as they are attached
to the particulars like they so so that
in some ways kind of like Aristotle but
they also believe he also believed that
these essences are you know wheels of
God that they are you know essences in
the mind of God so that they also do
have a kind of permanent reality and and
so that's it like that's the incarnation
of thinking to me that's the best way of
understanding incarnational thinking is
the best way to deal with Plato and
Aristotle and yeah how Christians let's
say may do with that alright so mark
Peters asked Jonathan do I have this
right as applied to biblical symbolism
historical events are acted out
according to their respective forms all
of which is from the divine the true
interpretation of the meaning comprises
these events the true interpretation of
the meaning comprising these events is
the logos thank you for your vocation
mark Peters I think that's a great way
to describe it I think you are you are
right and that's what I was talking
about before is that that the stability
of the events is not in the events the
events are real that I'm not saying that
it's all subjective or that it's all
relative nothing I seen any of that none
of that all I'm saying is that all I'm
saying is that the stability of the
event comes from the logos comes from
its purpose the very form of the event
comes from the purpose that you are
describing that event for that you're
noticing that you're realizing its
relevance to use John Dravet keys
language the fact that you're realizing
relevance that is that is the stable
pattern
out of which the the the they really
speak like him out of which the the the
event emerges from all possible events
and so and so I think that that's the
best way to understand it and I to me to
me it seems like that's even though I'm
quoting John robic he was not a
Christian I think that that's the best
way to to understand it so all right
Alicia Bruggeman asks can you please
give us your interpretation of the
Easter Bunny leaving chocolate eggs in
September come on man why are you asking
you this in September you should be
asking me this in April but uh alright
at least so sorry ah I mean for sure the
Easter Bunny that you stir thing and the
eggs it's all about fertility it's all
about spring as the moment where the
birds and the bees come out in all in
every manner and so I think that that's
that's just why it is it the idea of a
bunny which is an extremely fertile
thing and the egg which is an image of
fertility itself I think that that's
those things go together in terms of
Christianity I think it also has a level
of symbolism which is related to the egg
as an image of of life and of
resurrection and so the tradition of
painting eggs at Easter is one which
which is a Christian tradition I don't
know where it comes from though it might
come from before but it's not it when
people tell you that it's some Western
European tradition it was there in
Constantinople to it so it's it's it's
it seemed like a very ancient tradition
to to have these decorated eggs in in
terms of chocolate I don't know when
that happened the whole chocolate thing
but I mean for sure it probably is
related to the similar things in the
sense that chocolate is obviously some
is obviously and some what an
aphrodisiac and it is obviously also
related to just sweetness and so this
this whole idea of
Jilla tea and sweetness it's not that
hard to see how those go together
alright so I hope that but I don't know
enough about the history of that it'd be
interesting to look into to kind of how
that manifested itself maybe can give
some hints like I say usually that you
can't necessarily find the meaning in
the historical way it happened but
something I can give you little hints
and it can help you to to realign your
thinking so alright guys so we are done
with the that part of the QA I'm going
to go into the I'm gonna go into the the
Super chats alright let's see so I hope
I hope everything in the chat is going
ok I really struggled to me to stay on
top of the super chat and the chats at
the same time alright here we go so
Virginia Charlotte asks would you be
able to explain the key symbolic
differences between the the
understanding of the Holy Trinity that
the Orthodox and the Roman Church hold
I II procession of spirit am I am the
right thing here ie procession from of
spirit and son from Father versus
Filioque well I don't have them all
sorry I need to refresh this again guys
sorry alright ok so here they are that
that question was real though alright um
alright so to explain the Holy Trinity
the difference between the Orthodox and
the Roman Catholic vision of the Holy
Trinity well man so the idea of the idea
is that Charlemagne and his theologians
added a phrase to the creep which is
that the Holy Spirit proceeds from the
father and the son so they add added and
the son and there are places in
scripture where Christ like there's is
that place where Christ says he's going
to send the spirit and there are places
in scripture where he blows on the
Apostles and says receive the spirit and
so it seems like those are the verses
out of which the the the Western Church
wanted to add and the son so what is the
difference so the Orthodox Church has
never accepted the Filioque and they
believe that the that to say that in the
Creed is to confuse the persons is to
create a kind of weird confusion in
terms of how the Trinity works so the
the the Orthodox perception mostly is
that the father it's like God is the
father and God his logos is fully divine
and has its fully participating in the
father's nature which is divine and
uncreated and the spirit also its
proceeds from the father and is also
fully participating in the divine nature
okay so the idea is that that the God is
the father and so Christ is also God but
he's he's he's God to the extent that he
is the logos of the Father and so but if
he's fully godlike he's not less in
terms of hierarchy that's the mystery of
Christianity um and so that's how they
that's how the Orthodox see that if you
say that the Spirit proceeds from the
the the father and the son it's like the
what how does it work because God got in
the Father like God our Father
so how does it work it's confusing and
you can see that a little bit in the
images of the Trinity which the West
developed which is the we've got with an
old man on one side and Christ on the
other and then in the middle you see the
Holy Spirit which is kind of proceeding
from both at the same time now it's my
understanding that there is a way to
talk about procession of the spirit a
way that some people use to say a way we
could say would be something like the
spirit proceeds from the father through
the son something like that and so that
could so it's like just like the world
is created by God it's created by God
the Father using this the logos the
logos is the means by which God creates
the world so - in terms of of creation
that the spirit proceeds from the father
through the son something like that and
so you know I will tell you I would be
totally honest - guys I I really I trust
the church and I trust the I trust the
father's but I don't totally I don't
completely understand how the world is
different like what what totally comes
down from the different understandings
of the Trinity I tried to kind of figure
it out it seems like there's something
about that that I that I that I don't
like III myself prefer the Orthodox way
of describing the of talking about the
Trinity and I think that it's the way
that the entire tradition agreed to talk
about it but I don't totally understand
the consequences like some people say oh
because of the Filioque it's like
basically the Filioque is the reason for
the entire West like everything that
went wrong with the West is because of
the Filioque and it's like I struggled
understand like how why why that would
be like I can if you'd say nominalism I
can see it I can see causality between
between you know between akhom his way
of describing reality and how that filth
and his way of talking about God as
being completely so transcendent that
that there's no connection between him
and the world and that his that his will
could you know that God could desire
like that God could create a world where
evil was good a good would evil all that
kind of insanity it's like I can see
that as the cause of our problems but I
struggle to see the Filioque how it it
it filters down so you can you can put
that up to my lack of theological
understanding maybe but I don't totally
get it
so Virginia then asks is one structures
inherently less stable is one symbolic
structure inherently less stable is one
more prone to tyranny and disintegration
if it is misunderstood and misused see
that's that's exactly the that's exactly
the difficulty that I struggled to
understand and then she says your
thoughts on the energy essence
distinction would be helpful there too
that is something that I understand more
in terms of its effect on the world of
understanding that when you when you
talk about God to talk about the
unknowability of God's essence when I
talk about when we when I'm talking
about guys when I say God is beyond all
being God is beyond all things God is
not a being God is beyond everything you
know st. Maximus talks about being and
non-being together like God is the
infinite you know that's when we're
talking about the unknowability of of
the uncreated and I think that that has
to be maintained completely maintained
but the problem with that is if you
don't have something like the energy
essence energy distinction then you run
into the the problem that ahkam ran into
which is like okay so God is is
pletely unknowable completely completely
unknowable okay so then who cares about
God like he's just outside of so outside
of the world that whatever dude like I
mean does it matter like what are you
gonna do about it so but but if but if
you understand that God's energies fill
the world that God's will that God's
God's actions or that which hold the
world together while maintaining God's
unknowability it's like I can understand
that I could understand what that does I
could I get completely you see how that
is one of the keys to bringing back in
my opinion a truly symbolic world a
truly integrated world so so hopefully
one day I will have better intuitions
regarding the Filioque and the Trinity
so Jonathan ought asks like Jesus like
Jesus the Word of God incarnate died and
was raised that the law have to die so
it could be raised if so would it be
raised in different garments of skin hmm
very strange question uh to have to die
so that it could be raised I don't know
I I don't I don't know I don't totally
understand what you're getting at I
don't see why the law would have to die
yeah sorry man i i i think that i think
that that for sure the law is
transformed in terms of what christ
brings to the world it's as if one of
the things that christ does is he's
constantly showing the logos of things
he's constantly pointing to the meaning
pointing to the purpose you know it's
like he says these laws these laws that
you're doing do you know the purpose of
them do you understand that you know you
pay the tithe to dissin to that but the
fact that you're not helping your
neighbor
means that you don't understand the
purpose of the law you don't understand
what is this is aiming to and so he
wants to realign the law we talked about
that before today he wants the outer
performance to match the inner purpose
that's what Christ is doing and so
there's that there's a kind of
transformation of the laws which happens
in Christ interestingly enough sometimes
there's the flips sometimes it there's a
weird kind of like a flip but by me I'll
make a video about that one day about
how there's some laws that flip when
Christ comes all right all right so
Christian Chad asks hi Jonathan any
updates on Jordan's health um no I don't
have any updates on Jordan's health I I
had I had been having a few little
messages from him once in a while when I
would just write him in and I was mostly
concerned with his wife's health and I
didn't know what he was going through so
since I found out that he he he's gone
to rehab for this this prescription
medicine that he was that he was taking
I haven't written him I'm not sure I
don't know it's like I'm wondering if I
I just not sure if he wants to be
bothered or if he wants to be left alone
so so I might write him a little note or
something we'll see but no I don't have
any news I I learned it the same way you
guys did through Michaela's video all
right James David please discuss the
validity of scheduled liturgical fasting
seems it may be structuring
masculinizing something which is
inherently new setec what's feminine the
act of fasting I don't understand why
the act of fasting is feminine I I would
say that on the contrary I think the act
of fasting is very masculine in the
sense that the act of fasting is a
desire to
line up the body it's a desire to not be
dominated by the belly and so and so
that's why that's one of the reasons why
we fast see you fast in order to to show
how dependent you are on on your desires
on your on your belly and all of that
and at the same time try to to master
your your your desires and body so yeah
so I to me I don't see it as something
that is that is feminine in terms of the
schedule I mean usually we schedule we
fast me for an important feast you know
like like pasta or like Christmas you
know it's as if it's a kind of spiritual
discipline a spiritual preparation in
order to fully be able to participate in
the let's say the glory of the feast or
the you know when you when you when
you're delivering about your actions and
your discipline and your focused you
know once you know once you once you're
then let's say once you reach your goal
which is the feast you know it's it's
going to be a lot it's way more precious
than if it was just handed to you you
know what do you think about the Council
of trullo is it Orthodox doctrine that
the world is roughly 7,500 years old I
mean that they that's how the Orthodox
count the dates they count them from
they they they do some backtracking in
order to calculate the generations in
order to reach in order to reach let's
say the the the the beginning of Genesis
so is it Orthodox doctrine that the
world is roughly seventy seven thousand
five hundred years old
well is it doctrine I mean it's
definitely orthodox tradition I think
that our world is 7,500 years old I
don't have a problem with that it's
pretty good actually it's pretty good
pretty good estimate in terms of
understanding when any memory that we
have any tradition any actual connection
to the past that we have seems to not go
beyond that so so to me I don't have a
problem with that I don't that make
sense like art we don't have any we
don't have any tradition which goes
before let's say the beginning of the of
the the the the Mesopotamian culture
let's say or the the beginning of yeah
we don't we don't really have anything
before that anything which is before the
the beginning of the great cities in a
Mesopotamia the cities in India the
cities in Egypt in Egypt is really it's
a broken line anyways we don't we don't
really know what Egypt is about honestly
I don't think so so that that's the
longest line you can find is going about
7,500 years old so I would say our world
is about that old no matter how you look
at it I'm probably confusing you guys by
saying that stuff all right
okay so Travis Jordan asks seems like
Rumplestiltskin had power while he was
anonymous and knowing speaking Strava
Jordan by the way he gave $42 my
goodness Travis dude that's an that's a
that's amazing
sorry there was I was surprised by that
it seems like Rumplestiltskin had power
while he was anonymous and knowing
speaking his name then subordinated his
power how do you see the realm of the
anonymous and naming yes exactly they're
not knowing the
anonymous can give you a certain amount
of power if that should be obvious to
anybody who uses YouTube
anybody who goes on on on message boards
being anonymous can be extremely
powerful that's why that's why 4chan
played a rule in electing Donald Trump I
mean my goodness talk about power and so
anonymity has a certain kind of power
and it it has the it has a revolutionary
power it has the power to to change
things secretly you know then flip
things around that's what anonymous
power has and then naming is the
solution to that you know it's it's it's
not that complicated to think it's like
you're if you want to if you want to
change the established order or if you
want to have power on the established
order it's best that you act in the dark
it's best that you you know your spy
you're you're an 8-year double agent
you're you've infiltrated something all
of these all of these images of
anonymity or revolutionary images images
of of gaining power from it in place in
order to to take over right in rubble
stillson's case to get the King into to
own the king that's what Rumpelstiltskin
wanted he wanted the child of the girl
but ultimately what he wanted was the
child of the king and so he wanted to
through a hidden process to - to
infiltrate and to get the next king
right and so that is and then naming is
the opposite power naming is the power
of of shining light you know you
discover that that that watergate was
you know that secretly they were
secretly taping the democrats and that
they were getting information on the
Democratic convention and so you shined
the light on that and you
beause there there on misdoings and by
doing that by naming what what was
hidden you are able to take away its
power so yeah so that's why when she
names him she takes away all this power
because Rumplestiltskin is ultimately a
revolutionary character all right let me
see so I got and I've got a few more
that came up all right drew McMahon asks
do you have a specific definition of
truth that is most correct aristotle
aquinas etc JB Pease that which is best
for survival or something like that
seems to miss the mark um yeah um do I
have a definition of truth man alive
that is really tough um I would say I
would say a good definition of truth
could be close to something that that
Jordan is expressing though I think he's
expressing it in he's not expressing Lee
fully right a good definition of truth I
think could be something like that which
hits the mark
so if sin if transgression is that which
misses the mark truth is that which hits
the mark so truth is when it's kind of
incarnation --all it's like when the the
invisible aspect of something and the
visible body that it has not necessarily
visible or the date of the body that it
has fits together when those get
separated that's when we get
when we have a problem with truth so
either that's when you get hypocrisy
that's when you get lies is when you and
you say one thing and you do another
that's a lie when when you you you when
the thing you're saying doesn't fit the
the body that's untrue and so when those
fit together to me that's that's what's
true
it doesn't necessarily it doesn't
necessarily refer only to physical
phenomena when I mean a body it can be
all any kind of any kind of accumulation
of particulars that's as good as it's
gonna get for me you're trying to pit me
up against Aristotle and Aquinas I have
people coming for me
all right so Barry Cavett asks do you
think time being made of the past the
present and the future could be related
to God being made of the Father the Son
and the Spirit respectively so that's
the famous that's the famous which his
name I should know because Jordan named
his church after after that forget his
name somebody remember that guy anyways
no I don't like that idea honestly I
really struggle with that notion yeah so
I think that there are different kinds
of threes in terms of the past present
and future I think
more to do with something like that
which has been let's say that which has
happened that which has been revealed
and then the this potentiality which is
still in the dark and so you'd imagine
the the the the the present adds a yeah
guys I'm not gonna get there especially
in terms of the father-son the spirit I
I know that that is that that is an idea
that has been popular but I when I think
about it symbolically I just don't I
just don't see it and and I think that
the the yeah like the the the the past
and President had there's a there's a
different kind of a three which is more
like the center and two sides and I
think that that is closer to what the
the past and the present is sorry guys
all right so we are centered usually I
try to go for about an hour and a half
so let me see if something else came up
all right so I think we're done guys um
I don't see any more messages I see a
few of the super chats were deleted so I
would I would warn you guys just it just
to stay within normal boundaries in
terms of what you put you right in your
super chats and thanks for everybody
thanks for your attention thanks to
everybody who is uh who's supporting me
as well it's been a rocky road since the
flood and the all the support that I be
getting from you guys has been not only
helpful but life-saving so I really
appreciate it and I will continue to be
putting out once a month patron only
videos I will try to also be careful not
to be too arrogant in my future videos
and yeah I really enjoy this so I will
talk to all of you guys very soon
you